well let's talk now to the bella russian
opposition leader
svatlana tikanovskaya who's currently
in vilnius in lithuania thank you for
joining us today
um are you shocked by what has happened
of course i'm shocked personally because
a week ago
i had the same flight from grace to
vilnius and i suppose that this could
happen to me
but this happened a week later with
our uh activist and journalist uh
rahman pradesh and of course we couldn't
even expect that regime
uh will endanger lives of
percentages international person just
just to kidnap
one person
it does seem remarkable that such
blatant brazen action has been taken and
even
what appears to have been claims of a
bomb scare on board the plane in order
to bring it down is this a change of
tactics
from president lukashenko
uh i think this is this escalation of
repressions in belarus is the result of
impunity
because for ninth months already we are
fighting against regime after fraudulent
elections
and but regime still
feels impunity and you see they use
such awful methods of kidnapping people
and for sure we have to put much more
pressure on this regime
for them to stop violence and to release
political prisoners
what what sort of pressure then because
i mean he's been saying to my guests all
morning
you know international pressure in terms
of sanctions
and asset freezing was applied last year
it doesn't seem to have made any
difference
you know the list of sanctions uh
has to be much much wider uh
for everybody uh think twice uh before
doing any tortures or violence towards
people
because there were three packages of
sanctions list of sanctions
and by the least isn't rather wide it's
only 80
people on the sanction list while in
prisons
are more than thousand people so
uh sanctioned list has to be proud
personal uh sanctions and uh
very smart and targeted uh sanctions on
only on those
state enterprises that are pockets of
lukashanka
those increased sanctions though will
change what
in your view i mean are you seeing
something that will force
him out of office something that will
force him to have free and fair
elections
he doesn't seem like the type of person
who is going to back down
look our strategy is to have
negotiations
with regime because we don't want any
violence or blood in our country new
victims because
since august more than 35 000 people
have been already detained
so we chose civilized way of solving
political crisis in belarus and we want
negotiations
and to make a regime answer to our calls
for negotiations
uh with the aim of solving uh political
crisis and
having new elections this fall we have
to put uh
more pressure do you hold out any hope
of that happening at this stage
in such in these circumstances when the
whole country is
against a regime it's absolutely
unbelievable that that regime will last
long
the only question is how many victims
will be
during this uh fight for freedom and for
democracy so i'm i i'm i don't believe
i'm sure that these changes will come
soon
in terms of of this young man who was
arrested
from the play i mean they've gone to
extraordinary action
to to get their hands on on this
journalist
what is his fate likely to be now
uh now we uh don't have access to him
lawyer is already trying to
get him but we don't know the updated
information at the moment
but i'm sure that he's in awful
circumstances i'm sure that he's been
tortured
because he knows a lot of information he
was a
leader of one famous telegram channel
about
civil society about the situation in
belarus and he's considered to be
like private enemy of uh mukashenka
so we're really afraid not only for his
freedom but
for his life obviously you're in exile
currently in in lithuania do you see
any i mean if you were invited back for
any sort of
of of negotiations uh with
president lukashenko would you go would
you have any confidence
in returning back to your own country
you know first of all kashanka is not
the president he's ex-president of our
country he's lost
uh the election but uh i think that
these negotiations should take place on
neutral
territory because uh there is no
uh belief to lukashanka anymore and uh
you know it's it's safer for everyone to
help these negotiations in the third
country
svetlana tikanovskaya appreciate your
time this morning thank you
thank you